alors pour moi cette prime c'est Nantes
parce que clairement ça veut dire que
les agents RATP on va leur donner ça ils
vont venir au travail derrière il y a
des conditions d'attribution en rapport
à cette prime qui est une insulte à tous
les travailleurs pour avoir cette prime
il faut pas tomber malade
faut pas poser un son enfant ça veut
dire ma fille elle est malade elle a une
gastro faut que j'aille travailler
je ne dois pas aider ma maman qui est
malade c'est-à-dire projetant je ne peux
pas poser un soin dedans un accident de
travail un accident de travail je
n'aurais pas cette prime également
ils ont fait ça pourquoi parce qu'ils
sont dit sinon ça va être oui j'ai parce
que là j'ai pas pu venir mais c'est
parce que j'avais ça j'avais si ils
veulent donc en fait ils disent la prime
c'est pour vraiment un gars qui n'a
jamais manqué sachez qu'un truc et j'ai
un pote à moi qui travaille à la SNCF
qui est conducteur de train qui est un
très bon pote à moi qui joue au pasddle
avec moi d'ailleurs il est en train de
me laver mes affaires parce que je les
avais oublié voilà ils a récupéré hier
non mais c'est vrai je vous jure que
c'est vrai voilà et ben voilà c'est mon
pote Laurent il met pour info à la SNCF
la fameuse prise pour ne pas la fameuse
prime pour ne pas faire grève existe
depuis des années ça va pour certains
jusqu'à 2000 euros par mois et il est il
est il est il est conducteur c'est un
frérot vraiment c'est un alors
aujourd'hui vous êtes en train de me
dire qu'un collègue chauffeur de bus qui
va se prendre une patate
il va se dire
alors qui est comme vous dites qui va
être assidu qui va être là quoi qu'il
arrive parce qu'aujourd'hui un chauffeur
de bus c'est des insultes ces
incivilités c'est des agressions on
s'est craché dessus c'est un quotidien
qui est très très très très très
difficile moi je conduis les trains moi
je conduisais tout à fait nous on
demande au-delà de cette prime qui est
une insulte parce que pour nous c'est
clairement pour casser la grève du 10
novembre on le sait très bien nous ce
qu'on veut pour tous les collègues de la
RATP c'est de meilleure condition de
travail qu'on a plus on a plus et il
sait ce qu'ils sont en train de faire là
c'est c'est ce qui nous prouve tous les
jours aujourd'hui on travaille c'est un
meilleur salaire qui a rapport à
l'inflation
un agent RATP quand il rentre il démarre
il a 1900 et quelques bruts ça fait du
un chauffeur de a un machiniste un
cheval de bus il a 1500
16005 excuse-moi aujourd'hui
un chauffeur de bus aujourd'hui c'est
simple tu peux aller voir les annonces
que tu as combien on est tellement parce
que c'est toujours c'est compliqué des
fois ils font des samedis des fois ils
arrivent à faire des samedis des nuits
matins dis-moi franchement elles sont
plus dans les 1008 que dans les 1005
alors j'ai même des chauffeurs de bus
qui sont à 2002 2003
alors peut-être avant quand il faisait
peut-être des heures sup peut-être avant
quand il faisait des samedis des trucs
enlevé toutes les primes ça il faut bien
j'entends pas au courant aujourd'hui
avant les chauffeurs de bus travailler
en deux fois c'est à dire que quand il
travaillait sur cette amplitude
d'horreur de deux fois ça veut dire il
venait traverser à 9h il reprenait à à
13h et finissait à 17h amplitude ça peut
aller jusqu'à 13h ça veut dire que le
mec avait pas coachu pendant 4 heures il
est comme ça dans son dépôt et ça tu
l'as sur ton contrat au début c'est vrai
qu'il y aura moins de monde dans le bus
ah non c'est faux c'est faux parce que
avant le premier août le chauffeur de
bus qui faisait ça avait une prime de 12
euros aujourd'hui RATP a dit vous allez
faire toujours la même chose vous allez
travailler plus vous allez avoir moins
de repos vous allez toujours faire ces
deux fois mais en gros il y a plus de
compensation vous avez fait votre
entretien annuel
tu vas travailler plus
non ça n'arrivera pas
par exemple
de départ sur les 35 heures de départ
que tu as signé en brut si tu travailles
moins il peut pas
obligé c'est comme si toi tu fais des
heures sup donc
merci obligatoirement merci Ben
aujourd'hui ils sont au lieu de
aujourd'hui il y en a certains qui
travaillaient 7 heures c'est à dire
dépasser 7 heures il faisait des heures
sup des minutes plus ça veut dire qu'il
aujourd'hui c'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui ça veut dire qu'ils vont
dépasser mais ça rentre dans leur 7h30
que maintenant on se fait 7h maintenant
c'est à 7h30 ça veut dire maintenant
faut dépasser 7h30 pour pouvoir
commencer à toucher de l'argent en plus
d'accord donc la finalité on travaille
plus pour gagner moins ils nous ont
enlevé donc quand ils vont dire oui et
en plus faut avoir une chose hein
démissionnent démissionne parce que les
conditions de travail sont plus les
mêmes ce n'est plus les mêmes si
aujourd'hui tous les Français les
Franciliens galèrent
les conditions de travail donner des
exemples bah c'est simple comme je viens
de vous dire avant un machiniste pouvait
être volontaire travailler plus mais il
avait des compensations aujourd'hui
c'est intégrer à tout le monde et il y a
plus de salaire donc celui qui touchait
1000 8009 parce qu'il faisait des heures
sup' je l'entends j'ai entendu moi que
maintenant la RATP comme il trouve pas
de personne ils embauchent ils ont pris
des annonces sur le bon coin et alors et
à combien ils ont bossent les gens qui
rentrent tout de suite maintenant à la
RATP aujourd'hui ils sont capables de
prendre des jeunes de 18 ans et leur
donner 1450 € net c'est parce que
j'entends pour se faire insulter à la
civilité
donne-leur 2000 euros net tous les mois
je pense qu'ils vont trouver
sur les oui et elle a bah on a pas la
pas vraiment besoin de VOUS euh donc je
vais surtout dans la parole oui et
Bernard Montiel Benjamin Castaldi et non
regardez vos pancartes quand même pour
qu'on voit que vous êtes non euh Raymond
pourquoi vous dites vous êtes d'accord
avec cette démarche Benjamin Castaldi
parce que alors attention il faut pas
tout mélanger mais je trouve que la
prime pour quelqu'un qui démarre faut
pas tomber dans les ce qui se chie
dessus
50 €
à effectivement travailler il y a pas
entre guillemets je travaille pour des
petites raisons je pense que c'est
plutôt plutôt encourageant
de travail c'est pas pareil que les
parce que la prime que la prime
d'acidité
des gens effectivement à être plus
assidu au travail voilà donc en fait la
parole pour ne rien dire qu'est-ce que
tu as démarré c'est chié dessus est-ce
que c'est qu'un animateur
alors là j'estime tout ce que la cité
des incivilités et tout ça c'est un
support
en revanche je trouve ça très normal
quand même d'aller tous les jours au
boulot moi ça fait 38 ans que je suis à
la télé j'ai jamais manqué un jour parce
que tu as pas appelé ça quand on est
malade
avec vous effectivement si vous êtes
agressé vite agressé
une négociation à faire
c'est normal d'aller travailler tous les
jours au boulot
c'est pour casser la grève du 10
novembre on va être présent
entre vigueur de la prime c'est pas
chier dessus non la prime c'est pour
octobre novembre décembre moi non plus
hivernale où tout le monde doit avoir
des grippes des gastro le covid qui
remonte donc oui forcément on risque
d'être on n'aura pas cette c'est de la
poudre perlimpinpin personne Laura cette
prime et ça changera pas la chose je
voudrais un autre
oui après on reviendra sur caca mou
pour l'agression pour l'agression c'est
honteux d'enlever la prime pour une
agression parce que tu es pour rien
voilà les accidents de travail sont eux
après il faut savoir que dans tous les
métiers quasiment tous les métiers
notamment dans le transport dont je fais
partie il existe des primes d'acidité tu
as ton brut et si tu t'accentes pas dans
toute une année tu auras une prime de
1002 à 1500 elle existe la prime
d'acidité elle existe dans tous les
métiers ensuite je reviens sur ce que tu
dis surtout
pour ces trois mois là mais après il
faut la faire perdurer cette prime
d'acidité si la mettre pour 3 mois votre
combat à vous c'est de dire on la veut
pas pour 3 mois on l'a vu pour tout le
temps
embaucher et pour embaucher de ce que tu
dis moi de mon expérience à moi de tous
les potes que j'ai avec son chauffeur de
bus ou chauffeur de métro j'en ai aucun
qui touche 1400 je te le redis encore à
la RATP aujourd'hui avec les les
contrats là un contrat 35 heures à 1400
€ avec un permis car avec un permis de
venir la pdgr qui n'est plus là
aujourd'hui c'est pas Jean Castex qui va
arriver parce que elle bah elle a eu des
problèmes familiales parce que
d'un milieu excuse-moi des problèmes
familiaux on est bien d'accord elle est
partie on apprend trois semaines après
là on peut pas lui en vouloir gynéco
pour 2 millions d'euros pas de problème
donc elle elle a fui le bateau qui
chavirent et derrière on va on va voir
qui J'encaisse mais il est là pourquoi
lui pour la réforme des retraites et
vous voilà donc c'est ça tout ça plus ça
plus ça plus ça vous êtes content de que
j'encaisse au patron
encore plus nous casser nous enlevez
tous nos avantages qui peut rester il y
a quasiment plus et voilà et on va vers
la privatisation
là je pense qu'il était là il arrive
et sur la route là il arrive avec son
attache
ma filtrer je vais regarder comment ça
se passe mais il est sympa
elle t'a convaincu ou pas non non pas du
tout parce que non pas du tout
non attendez on parle d'une prime
d'assiduité que l'on dit Raymond on va
pas tout mélanger les concentrations de
travail etc les gens je trouve ça normal
d'aller bosser tous les jours c'est vrai
il a il a il a pas tort excusez-moi une
prime c'est toujours meilleur que de
rien voilà donc après après on va
travailler
mais certains trucs mais pas tout il y a
pas touché
je crois que j'ai une angine j'ai trop
j'ai 39 degrés je vais prendre le volume
en bus et rouler pendant 7 ans et il est
là non mais c'est vrai
il y a plein de métiers quand on a une
petite angine etc excusez-moi il y a pas
quand on a un rhume quand tu conduis un
bus faut faire attention de sécurité
après faut vous battre sur les
incivilités la sécurité pour faire mais
la pression
c'est la bonne chose mais non
vous absenter ça c'est faux il y a
beaucoup de démission et ils arrivent
pas à embaucher et beaucoup de départ en
retraite il n'arrive pas à embaucher il
n'arrive pas à embaucher pourquoi qui
veut venir travailler aujourd'hui dans
une insécurité permanente en travaillant
à 5h du matin donc automatiquement
prendre notre voiture moi j'aurais
préféré qu'il y a une prime essence
donnez-nous une primessence parce que 5h
du matin
vous avez regardé il y a 47 % non à 53%
oui c'est michmich